hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm going to
explain a 2010 american science fiction
and action movie called tron legacy
in 1989 kevin flynn ceo of a technology
company called ncom tells his son sam
the story of his adventures in the grid
the grid is a virtual reality where disc
battles in a spectacular arena cycles
that race on ribbons of lights and lots
of miraculous things happen there it is
created by kevin alongside tron and clu
who appears to be a program in kevin's
own image that could thank
sam is eager to know more about his
dad's story but is told to wait for next
time as kevin leaves for work before he
goes he invites his son to go to the
arcade tomorrow and toss a coin to him
suddenly the scene cuts to a montage of
events and news reporting about kevin's
disappearance causing chaos in the
company the news also tells about the
income company which skyrocketed to the
top of the tech industry while kevin is
taking charge as the ceo
it is also discovered that in 1985 sam's
mother died because of a car crash
leaving sam as an orphan one of kevin's
friends alan bradley insists that kevin
is not missing and is instead pursuing
his dream of discovering something
magical
the scene jumps to 2010 sam who now
becomes encom's primary shareholder
after his father's disappearance breaks
into ncom tower and attempts to steal
the company's newest operating system os
12 but is spotted by the company's
security guard on the other hand richard
mackey current chairman of the company
states that os 12 which previously was
sold free now will be a paid software
because it is claimed to be one of the
safest software in the world and there
is no reason to sell it for free sam
manages to hack into the ncom system and
releases the os 12 to the public for
free on its release day as part of his
annual prank to the company making
michael furious after being chased to
the top of the tower by the security
guard sam reveals himself as the biggest
shareholder of ncom and then attempts to
free fall off the tower with his
parachute as he tries to reach his
motorbike he is arrested by the police
for trespassing but is eventually
released a few hours later
sam returns to his apartment where he is
confronted by allen who tells him about
a page signal he received from sam's
father's office in the arcade which has
been disconnected for 20 years
allen also shares a story about kevin
who came to allen's house two days
before he disappeared and claimed that
he had cracked the code about quantum
teleportation allen also adds that kevin
wouldn't have left that invention and
wouldn't have left his only son
sam doesn't believe his story and says
that kevin is already dead and does not
care about him anymore before alan
leaves he hands over the arcade key to
sam saying that he must be the one who
goes there and finds out what is
happening later on the night sam decides
to pay a visit to the arcade and manages
to locate a hidden doorway behind the
tron arcade machine which leads him to a
secret workshop underneath the playing
room sam explores through his father's
computer and activates a digitizing
laser behind him by accident
transporting him into the digital world
called tron city
the confused sim then walks out from the
arcade building realizing that
everything has changed in the city has
transformed into a very modern and
digitized city called grid he is then
captured by and recognizer and is
assigned by the program to participate
in the games all the others are being
rectified
sam is then taken down to a room where
he is equipped with armor and an
identity disc which records everything
its holder does or learns
after that he is delivered to disk wars
arena where he has to fight several
programs and has to be the last man
standing in order to win the game
after several breathtaking fights he has
to face a program named rinzler the only
program who uses two identity discs
while fighting in the final fight
rinsler seems to be a much stronger and
experienced fighter than sam as he is
outskilled by the program
when rinzler is about to launch his
final blow he notices blood coming from
sam and suddenly recognizes him as a
user the grid's boss who has been
watching the entire fight from a flying
ship commands the fighter to bring sam
to him as the two meet sam believes at
first that he is talking to his father
before realizing that it is clu when he
says that he is not his father who
apparently has the same image and
appearance with his father as described
in the beginning of the movie
after the encounter sam is being sent to
the next game which is light cycle grid
while a masked woman watches them
unnoticed
surprisingly he is assigned with a team
challenged directly by clu and his
followers
equipped by a futuristic motorcycle the
battle begins
members from both teams are slowly
eliminated one by one until sam and clu
become the final survivor
sam falls off from his bike and clu is
coming after him luckily the mysterious
woman comes with his futuristic car
saving him from being killed by clu both
of them then escape from the arena and
she introduces herself as cora while
driving away the grid
they eventually arrive at a safe house
far outside the grid where sam finally
meets his long-awaited father and they
hug
at dinner kevin explains to his son that
he was working with tron and clu to make
grit into a perfect system
however a brand new type of program
manifested itself within the grid they
are called isomorphic algorithms or isos
and were considered as a miracle by
kevin and his story to sam at the
beginning of the movie before his
disappearance
kevin felt they represented
revolutionary potential to change the
human condition
clu who saw them as aberrations betrayed
kevin and tron in order to take control
of the system and purge it of all isis
tron who was designed to be a warrior
fought back for kevin and was destroyed
by clu
since then tron was never seen again
while kevin managed to flee kevin
remained trapped in the grid when the
portal back to the real world closed
causing him to disappear for a very long
period of time
he adds that the portal can only be
opened from the outside of the grid
sam insists on taking his father out of
the grid and returning home because the
portal will remain open for eight hours
in grid but kevin refuses as this is
exactly what clu has been planning to
lure the creator into the grid and then
try to obtain his disk kevin's identity
disc contains a lot of valuable
information that will endanger the real
world if it was stolen by clu because it
will allow him to be transferred into
the real world
sam also discovers that the page signal
received earlier by allen was not sent
by kevin but clu
sam is optimistic if he could make it to
the portal even without his dad he and
alan could shut down clu from the
outside wanting to help cora hands over
a map containing the location of a
program named zeus who may be able to
help sam
against his father's wish sam takes his
father's light cycle and goes back to
the grid
later on the night kevin finds his son
missing and finally decides to come out
of hiding to go after his son
upon arrival sam abandons the light
cycle in the middle of the city causing
clu's operatives to trace its point of
origin which is kevin's safehouse clu
and his army immediately travel to the
safe house but finding no one as kevin
has gone away
sam is brought by a woman called gem to
zeus's clubhouse called end of line club
there he meets caster and caster brings
him to his private room where he reveals
that he is actually zeus he then betrays
sam to clu whose army called blackguard
suddenly appears at the club and starts
killing everyone cora and kevin arrive
just in time to assist sam
unfortunately cora's arm is destroyed in
the ensuing brawl forcing them to flee
from the club
as the trio escape one of the black
guards attempts to steal kevin's disk
and zeus manages to take it from the
guard
zeus hands over the identity disc to clu
hoping that both of them could build a
mutual relationship
but he is then betrayed by clu who
explodes the entire club killing both
zeus and gem in the process
kevin and sam argue over their next
course of action finally decide to take
a freight train called solar sailor to
the portal as he is repairing korra's
arm kevin reveals that korra is the last
surviving iso
while on their way in waiting for
korra's system rebooting sam and kevin
bond with each other upon awakening cora
shares her story about how she met kevin
who saved her from an assault
she also has a desire to see what the
real world looks like
unexpectedly the solar sailors route has
been diverted taking them to a massive
carrier ship where clu is repurposing
programs in order to form his own army
as they try to find a way out core
decides to sacrifice herself to distract
the enemy ends up getting captured by
renzler and is brought to clu
when fighting with cora kevin realizes
that rinsler is actually tron who has
been repurposed by clu
clu gives a speech towards his army of
repurposed programs about his grand plan
to rule the real world
having secured kevin's identity disc he
is now able to take his carrier and army
to invade the real world while kevin is
trying to find a plane for their escape
sam decides to go to clu's command ship
in order to save cora and take back the
identity disc
he manages to retrieve the disc when
rinsler suddenly comes to the ship with
cora both of them have a rematch and
with cora's help they manage to disarm
him and leave him hanging over the ledge
they then escape and finally meet kevin
on the flying deck
while on their way to the portal kevin
sam and cora are confronted and chased
by clu rinzler and his black guards
sam with his machine gun and cora with
his piloting skill managed to eliminate
all the black guards leaving clu and
rinzler in the opposing team
when kevin makes eye contact with
rinzler he begins to regain his memories
as tron and abandons the chase leaving
clu to pursue them alone
suddenly rinsler turns back and
purposely crashes his jets towards clues
in freefall clu manages to steal
rinsler's backup jet and continues his
chase towards the group leaving rinzler
to fall into the sea
as the trio fly towards the portal kevin
asks cora to swap their identity disk
upon arrival at the portal's gate they
have been waited by clu kevin and clu
start their conversation where clu
claims that he was simply following the
directive programmed into him he insists
that it was kevin who betrayed his
promise to make a perfect world together
kevin accepts the fact that he was wrong
at some point and apologizes for setting
clu on such an impossible task
clu suddenly attacks kevin and sam tries
to fight back but gets thrown away
instead to the other side of the bridge
the bridge to the portal starts to break
off separating sam and cora while clu
goes for kevin's disc but he is shocked
to find out that he has been tricked
because it is cora's disc
frustrated and furious clu jumps to
reach sam and cora but it's too late as
they have got inside the portal kevin
then reintegrates with clu causing them
to explode and destroy the entire world
back in the real world sam copies the
grid from kevin's old servers onto a
small microchip he wears around his neck
allen then arrives at the arcade after
receiving another page where sam states
that he will take over ncom and choose
allen as the chairman he also adds that
alan was right about everything
cora surprisingly appears in the real
world and sam decides to bring her to
see the sunrise for the first time
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching